after she began working on Nashville
pantier decided to pack up and move to
the city for which the show is named she
purchased a home in Nashville and
subsequently realized that she was much
happier living there instead of in New
York City or Los Angeles she felt like
she could be more laid-back and more
true to herself moreover she told
Southern Living that she appreciated
that her new neighbors seemed to Value
the little things in life allowing her
to slow down and stop focusing on the
non-stop hustle of life in the enter
entertainment industry she continued the
people here are amazing living in
Nashville gives me a sense of normaly
that I wasn't sure I was ever going to
get back in my life when I first got
here all my defenses were still up and I
was waiting for that world to suddenly
creep back in when it didn't I realized
that I can live a normal life here with
people who don't judge you based on what
you do or who you are in the public eye